hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa and I wouldn't
saw ready for one I wanted to dress up
for this and the only costume that I had
that was in the movie was Freddy Krueger
though I wish I had an Iron Giant
costume because damn it did I love him
in this film though this is getting
sweaty so I'm going to take i'ma take
him off so I loved this movie with all
of my heart there were definitely a few
pacing issues some problems I think even
maybe some casting issues but overall my
enjoyment of the film was just massive I
had such a good time with it
it was incredibly engaging as just a
film but as like a nerd based person and
especially a gamer based person it was
so exciting to watch there were so many
references to film and gaming and just
nerd culture and that was so fun and
didn't feel like a way for them to be
like please like this movie look here's
the Iron Giant which I felt in the
trailers I felt that way in the trailers
I was like oh man they're just gonna
like do a cheap grab of the Iron Giant
to get everyone back on their side but
it really didn't feel like that in the
actual film I'm not going to give any
crazy spoilers though it's a book and
there's not really anything crazy
spoilery about it it's pretty much
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory
or Willy Wonka in the chocolate the
first one whatever the first one was
remake but it was basically that but
with video games which is pretty sweet
oh it literally says Wonka and the
matrix meet on the cover I bought this
book off of loot crate in Vault awhile
back it was like a dollar and I had full
intentions of reading it and I then I
heard from a lot of people Rob Walker a
lot of people on Twitter everyone was
saying that the book is pretty slow and
boring so I decided against reading the
book I just kind of wanted to go in
blind and enjoy it from what it was I
really enjoyed the film adaptation of
this and I wonder if you have read the
book if maybe it's not as good because
you you liked the book or because you
didn't like the book so now you don't
really you know what I mean I was
talking about this last week when I
talked about Pacific Rim - and Pacific
Rim one that that's a film that if you
go in and you have a lot of fun with it
you're just gonna have you know stupid
blast like it's gonna be a stupid fun
dumb movie that you're gonna have a good
time with and I didn't go into it with
those expectations I kind of went into
it like super critical for some reason
and I didn't enjoy them and I think that
was because of the mindset I went into
it with this is a very similar film if
you go into it just try to have a fun
nerdy pop culture II Adz time you're
gonna have such a good time I was just
so elated by all of the references and
this story and the CGI and everything
really worked for me
I think people are going into it like I
went into Pacific Rim just a little like
wanting it to not do well it felt like
very like an homage to the 80s in some
respects and in other respects it's so
futuristic it's all CGI taking place in
this online virtual reality world it
looks good - it looks better than I
would have imagined it would look I
loved that kind of sense of like World
of Warcraft like creating your own
character I think by far the scenes that
took place in the Oasis which is the
virtual reality world in film were a lot
more interesting than the scenes that
took place in real life at least to a
certain point we got like two-thirds of
the way in and every time they kind of
popped out and we're in real life and
we're people it wasn't as interesting it
was much more interesting in the Oasis
then about one third of the way left in
the film it ramped up and it got a lot
better and the stakes were higher and
the chemistry was better I am a little
confused about the casting of the lead
character he was a little dead to me I
didn't love that casting and he was such
a cool and vibrant and interesting
character in the Oasis and it's still
you and still your personality
and your voice and so I don't know I
thought that was a little weird the
casting there was a little weird
I loved the casting of the lead female I
loved the casting of the friends when
you get to see the real-life person of
all these online personas that you've
been seeing in the film so far it's
really fun to put them together and to
see who's been playing who Simon Pegg
was in this movie which was really great
they did an amazing makeup on him to
make him look a lot older right away I
just wrote as a gamer this rules it's
just so fun to see this really good
video game movie it's not based on a
video game obviously but it's a movie
about essentially a giant video game so
the story is about the creator of the
Oasis what he passes away he creates an
easter egg in the Oasis that is going to
let the person who finds it inherit all
of the Oasis and like what happens to it
all this money ends up it's very
difficult to find you find three
different keys and complete three
different tasks to get the final prize
and it's been going on for I think it
was five years and no one had even found
the first key so Wade watts our lead
character goes in and with the help of a
small crew of friends he's met in the
Oasis finds the keys but more than just
trying to find the Easter egg win this
power and win this money it's about the
love of the game for our lead character
Wade watts he loves the game he loves
the Creator holiday and it's really fun
to see you know these giant corporations
one in particular trying to find it to
inherit this power and then this group
of friends trying to find it to save the
world of that super power and save the
worlds of this you know corporate
control and then also just trying to
find it out of the love of the game my
favorite part in this film without
giving too much away is a sequence that
takes place in the movie The Shining
it's where one of the keys is held and
it's just so wonderful
I wrote the chemistry isn't amazing
between the Wade watts and Samantha I
think her name is Samantha I didn't I
love Wade watts I didn't love him and
he's the lead I loved him in the Oasis
like I said Ben got a little dry a
little bit
boring some things in the film seemed a
little rushed and some seemed so slow
mainly the scenes between the two beads
and then the four sweetest words ever
were uttered activate the Iron Giant yes
I love the Iron Giant that's my favorite
animated film of all time Wade's friend
H in the Oasis has this really cool
workshop where he works on robots and
you see the Iron Giant like deactivated
and they activate and then the Iron
Giant is fighting a giant Godzilla and
this is the giant monster versus giant
robot fight that I wanted after out of
Pacific Rim honestly the Iron Giant
stuff made by goddamn life I was very
into the Iron Giant and I knew I was
going to be I went in thinking like even
if it's not good I'm just really excited
to see the Iron Giant in a live-action
film live-action you know it was all CGI
I ended up really enjoying the film but
the moments with the Iron Giant really
made me so happy and I don't want I
won't give anything away but it was just
so good the comedy was really lovely - I
laughed it like 98% of the attempts at
comedy I loved one of the villains I
rock he added a lot of comedy and it was
TJ Miller who I don't sorry but I don't
usually love TJ Miller and and I thought
as a voice actor for this was so good
much better than the men emoji and then
the last thing I wrote was those lips
who's the lead character has some big
big finally kids if I kiss the girl at
the end obviously and my brother and I
both just went like you're gonna suck
her up there but I mean that's a good
people love big lips it's so good I'm
not knocking it I'm just saying it was a
thing that I notice all in all I think
that this film was so much fun and maybe
I am just the absolute perfect
demographic for this maybe I do just
love almost every film but I have such a
good time with it I think if you go into
it expecting it to be like this kind of
like silly dumb
which is but just fun throwback to
things that you love I don't know I just
don't see how you could not enjoy it
definitely there was a few problems but
a lot less problems than most of the
time when I'm like I loved it but it's
not great I loved this and it was pretty
great I think boy I don't think it was
it's getting so much negative feedback
from a lot of critics and reviewers and
I I guess I just didn't see it I'm
obviously not a critic or reviewer just
like to yell at the camera a lot so I
don't know maybe I missed that some
really big like film flaws but just as
like a viewer as a movie viewer I
thought it was super fun I've really
enjoyed it and I would absolutely
recommend it I would super recommend
seeing this in theaters thank you so
much for watching I will see you guys
all next week with a quiet place I'm so
excited to see so I cannot wait for this
film so please check that out I will see
you all next week
[Music]